bonjour à tous aujourd'hui mon histoire
commence la tête baissée mon histoire
commence en marchant dans la rue dans un
parc sur la plage en fait mon histoire
commence en regardant la trace que
l'humanité laisse au quotidien
je ne parle pas de ça de ça ou de ça
mais je parle plutôt de tout ce qui est
papiers canettes chewing gum bouteilles
plastiques emballages de fast food et
aujourd'hui je suis là pour vous parler
dans des chais qui est devenu tellement
omniprésent qu'on ne voit plus je vais
vous parler du premier déchet mondiale
alors quel est il
voilà quelques indices je suis blanc
l'intérieur et orange à l'extérieur on
me trouve sur le sol et dans les cours
d'eau et je sens particulièrement
mauvais je pense que tout le monde là à
peu près vous aurez compris que je parle
pas d'un vieux milliardaire qui sera en
train de cramer sur une plage au mali
mais je parle d'un déchet à l'aspect
cotonneux le mégot de cigarette
chaque minute en france assez de mégots
sont jetés pour atteindre le sommet du
mont blanc
un seul mégot à la capacité de polluer
jusqu'à 500 litres d'eau 500 litres
c'est l'équivalent de 3 baignoire pleine
un mégot en fait un mégot c'est de
l'acétate de cellulose ou autrement dit
une espèce de plastique imbibé de 4000
substances toxiques et parmi ces
substances on va trouver du plomb de
l'arsenic encore du goudron et
malheureusement cette toxicité
en fait le troisième déchets le plus
mortel dans nos océans
après le matériel de pêche et les sacs
plastiques
c'est simple si vous mettez un mégot
dans un aquarium au bout de quelques
heures la moitié des poissons qui s'y
trouvent seront morts
chaque année à paris ses 350 tonnes de
mégots qui sont ramassés dans les rues
est ce que vous vous rendrez compte ça
nous fait quasiment une tonne par jour
seulement sur paris de mégots par terre
juste par terre et vous pouvez imaginer
que tout cela a un coût à votre avis ça
coûte combien par an en france le
ramassage de ces mégots un million deux
millions 10 millions 280 millions
d'euros chaque année en france juste
pour ramasser les mégots par terre
280 millions d'euros ça représente deux
fois le budget alloué au développement
de l'agriculture en france ça c'est un
paquet d'impôt qui partent en fumée et
ses 280 millions d'euros ne prennent
même pas en compte les frais nécessaires
à la dépollution des eaux usées quand un
mégot fini dans le caniveau
ni les frais nécessaires à
l'incinération et à l'enfouissement de
ce déchet parce que finalement
aujourd'hui la meilleure des solutions
c'est celle de mettre son mégot de
cigarette avec ses ordures ménagères et
ce manque à gagner a bien été identifié
par les villes et c'est pour ça qu'elle
nous met en place de grandes campagnes
de sensibilisation à plusieurs milliers
d'euros
de nouvelles lois des interdictions et
même des amendes mais alors à quel
moment on se dissocie autant des déchets
que nous produisons à quel moment on est
capable de mettre quelque chose à notre
bouche laisser un fluide toxiques
rentrer dans nos poumons altérer notre
organisme jouer sur la fluidité de notre
sens sur l'acidité de notre corps sur la
composition de notre peau pour s'en
débarrasser aussi vite et faire comme si
ce rapport très intime n'avait jamais
existé
chacun de nos choix chacune de nos
décisions est un pari sur l'avenir
alors oui on peut prendre la décision d'
altérer notre organisme en mangeant
n'importe quoi en fumant en buvant mais
par contre décidé d' altérer nos seuls
notre air notre eau qui sont des biens
communs ne devrait pas pouvoir se faire
d'une simple pichenette de la main savez
vous que chaque jour ses vingt-deux
mille tonnes de plastique
supplémentaires qui arrive dans l'océan
chaque jour savez vous également que 90
% des oiseaux marins aujourd'hui ont
déjà ingéré du plastique en fait à quel
moment on s'est dit que l'excitation
procurée par un lâcher de ballons à un
mariage valet ce résultat à quel moment
on s'est dit qu'on allait consommer de
l'eau conditionnée dans des bouteilles
en plastique bourré de perturbateurs
endocriniens
alors qu'on a la chance de vivre dans un
pays où l'eau qui coule de notre robinet
est potable l'eau et le produit
alimentaire le plus contrôlé de france
où est passé notre bon sens et si on
continue comme ça d'ici 2050 il y aura
plus de plastique queue de poisson dans
l'océan alors d'accord une bonne
nouvelle c'est que l'on peut agir au
quotidien talent colibri ya plein de
choses à faire au quotidien
on peut par exemple tout simplement
bannir la vaisselle plastique utilisé
des sacs en tissu utilisait savants et
shampoings solide on peut mettre un stop
pub sur notre boîte aux lettres on peut
bannir les pailles on peut utiliser des
cendriers de poche on peut interpeller
et sensibiliser les gens autour de nous
bref tout un tas de choses qui sont bien
connus mais qui valent vraiment la peine
d'être remémorer est réellement mises en
place et personnellement quelque chose
qui me permet de garder le cap une
phrase qui me fait régulièrement changer
mes habitudes c'est l'exemple n'est pas
le meilleur moyen de convaincre
il est le seul
et c'est pour ça que depuis bientôt deux
ans j'ai décidé non pas seulement d'agir
chez moi mais j'essaye de mettre en
place des solutions pour le plus grand
nombre
et c'est là qu'on en revient à nos
mégots de cigarettes en faisant des
roches ans de recherches sur internet je
tombe sur des articles disant qu'ils
décrivent en l'impact environnemental et
budgétaires du mégot de cigarette
je découvre aussi qu'il est possible de
recycler ce déchet en fait d'un côté on
a la partie organique et le resto de
tabac et le papier qui va être
transformé en compost urbain tandis que
le filtre donc en acétate de cellulose
va être dépollué refondu en petites
billes plastiques et ce plastique va
servir à faire du mobile et des jardins
des palettes des plaques de construction
etc
c'est simple une tonnes de mégots nous
donne 650 kg de plastique et c'est
autant de pétrole à ne pas aller forêt
sous nos sols on a donc d'un côté les
usines de recyclage qui existent dont
une en france en bretagne et de l'autre
on a les tonnes de mégots généré partout
dans le monde chaque année et encore
trop peu d'acteurs pour faire le lien
entre les deux et c'est là que
l'aventuré humaine ni des nez on était
cinq étudiants à se dire ok comment on
fait maintenant pour que les fumeurs
face les cinq passes supplémentaires
nécessaires dans la rue pour aller jeter
leurs mégots de cigarettes au bon
endroit
c'est là qu'on a décidé de créer le
premier cendrier connectés au monde
la borne wi cycl alors pourquoi
connecter tout simplement pour venir
gainey fier et rendre ludique le fait de
recycler pour cela c'est très simple en
fait
out chaque borne vous avez une question
à laquelle vous pouvez répondre de
manière binaire donc réponse à une
réponse b et l'utilisateur va venir
répondre à cette question en rejetant
son mégot du côté choisi
du coup nous on procède à la fois une
collecte de déchets mais aussi une
collecte de données car la borne wi cycl
est relié à l'internet des objets et du
fait que ce soit un objet connecté la
bande devient un outil de
sensibilisation
on va prendre un exemple charles est
fumeur et charles les salariés chez la
poste et il se trouve que comme tous les
salariés fumeurs charles va consommer
entre 70 et 80
cent de ces cigarettes sur son lieu de
travail donc la poste a eu l'excellente
idée d'installer des bornes sur les
zones fumeurs tandis que charles a
téléchargé l'application greenman guide
et dès qu'il va venir déposer un mégot
dans une borne
ça va être comptabilisés de manière
transparente sur son smartphone et s'il
le veut à la fin de chaque mois pour
avoir un feedback lui disant bravo
charles ce mois ci tu as fumé x % nos
cigarettes en moins que le mois
précédent
tu as gagné x % des capacités
respiratoires j'avais économisé tant
d'argent etc etc donc charles lui il est
ravi d'avoir ce coach virtuel
gratuitement mis à disposition par son
employeur et en plus shargh la même pas
à sortir sur smartphone de sa poche
grâce à notre système de détection
automatique
alors il est important de préciser que
toutes les informations collectées à
propos de charles reste strictement
confidentielles c'est seulement pour lui
et l'employeur n'a aucun regard sur qui
fument ou non au sein de ses locaux
mais alors pourquoi l'entreprise
paierait pour un tel service
bah c'est simple une étude de
l'université de l'ohio a montré qu'un
salarié fumeurs coûte en moyenne 6000
euros de plus par an à salariés non
fumeurs désolé pour les fumeurs
c'est c'est dû notamment aux pauses
cigarettes aux congés maladie est ce
qu'on appelle le présentéisme c'est à
dire le fait de rester plus longtemps
sur son lieu de travail pour justement
compenser les pauses plus fréquentes
donc là parce que je viens de décrire
c'est seulement si la borne et sur mon
lieu de travail mais ici je suis dans
une ville où mon entreprise n'a pas
installé de cendrier on va prendre le
second scénario celui avec christelle
qui habite à paris au cristal et
fumeuses et la ville de paris a eu
l'excellente idée d'installer des bornes
à la sortie des gares des métros des
salles de spectacles etc
christelle à télécharger l'application
ville mendeala dès qu'elle va venir
déposer un mégot dans une borne ça va
être comptabilisés sur son smartphone
elle va gagner un point et plus elle va
recycler plus elle va cumuler ces points
sur une cagnotte de vire
tu l qu'au bout d'un moment elle va
pouvoir redistribuer en argent à une
association de protection de
l'environnement ou de lutte contre le
tabac de cette façon on crée un espèce
de cercle vertueux où le tout un chacun
gagne à recycler bon et maintenant
aujourd'hui quand je vous dis greenline
guide de quoi je parle
aujourd'hui green man dit c'est 100 kg
de mégots collecter ces dix points de
collecte déployer ses plus de 600
cendriers de poche distribué
gratuitement dans les rues et ses plus
de dix mille personnes sensibilisées à
travers six pays différents
grâce aux différents événements et
concours auquel on a participé et tout
cela sans investissement si ce n'est un
véritable investissement personnel
un investissement en termes de temps en
fait green ended c'est une bande
d'étudiants quelques paires de mains
quelques neurones qui se connectent et
beaucoup de coeur alors certes on avance
à tout petits pas ça fait bientôt deux
ans qu'on est sur le projet pour ceux
qui arrivent à se propre payer on se
paye grâce au rsa aux bourses aux aides
sociales
en même temps on se dit que si on le
fait pas personne ne le fera
et puis c'est simple parce qu'une fois
qu'on aura démocratiser le recyclage des
mégots bien pourra s'attaquer au sillage
de tous les autres petits déchets
oubliés mais going home qui il beauchamp
stylos etc
en fait on veut que la valorisation du
déchet devienne un automatisme et que la
mentalité qui aujourd'hui est basé sur
consomment et jette deviennent
consomment et valorise et puis regardez
autour de vous vous avez des objets
connectés pour tous vous avez des mondes
connectés des balance connectée même des
sous vêtements connectés mais par contre
personne n'a pensé à faire d'objets
connectés pour contrer la première
source de pollution mondiale est la
première cause de mortalité évitable au
monde
nous on trouve ça complètement dingue
et c'est pour ça qu'on a décidé de créer
ce premier cendrier connectés mondiale
la borne depuis cinq ans
alors aujourd'hui si vous voulez nous
aider c'est simple parlez-en autour de
vous s'il vous plaît ne restait plus
silencieux devant un mégot qui est jeté
dans le caniveau offrait des cendriers
de poche à votre entourage
et si vous voulez nous soutenir reminded
vous pouvez utiliser le moteur de
recherche lilo en fait c'est une
alternative aux moteurs de recherche
traditionnels qui permet de nous
financer au quotidien grâce aux
recherches que vous faites sur internet
aujourd'hui grâce à lille où on a déjà
gagné plus de 3000 euros
ça paraît rien comme ça mais c'est
énorme pour nous donc voilà maintenant
vous savez et à ce qui paraît savoir
c'est pouvoir
merci de m'avoir écouté
et vous pouvez nous retrouver sur notre
site internet et les réseaux sociaux
merci
[Applaudissements]